all right we are wrapping up wayne  newton week here on good day las vegas  and earlier in the show that you heard  him say it he doesn't believe in  retirement but he did just celebrate his  80th birthday so how do you honor a man  who's the essence of this city and show  business he's got an idea that's all  right  you just celebrated her birthday  did i  you know why  you know what i've done heather  i figured it out okay  if i didn't want to celebrate birthdays  i booked a flight to australia  the day before my birthday  and when i arrived there of course that  day didn't exist  because it's a day later there and then  i stay for three or four days and come  back and i get the day back i don't get  the birthday so i like that idea  wayne newton up close and personal at  the flamingo three nights a week tickets  on sale now and if you'd like to watch  all of the segments that we aired this  week they're on our website eight news  now dot com sherry it has been a fun  week kind of